foreign
all these videos on memorable and
legendary character entrances so why not
proceed with the next logical character
fathers father characters in anime
especially actions Shonen are some of
the most important ones often mentors
usually Rivals and always awesome that's
why for today we'll be looking at some
of my favorite father entrances in
battle Shonen and let's get things
started with issuance entrance
foreign
oh is it
how fitting bleach just came back and
we're starting off with ishin Kurosaki
one of the anime dads whose real
personality and awesomeness portray his
first impressions ishin from the get-go
looked like one of those joke characters
who wouldn't play a role in the main
overarching plot of the story but it
can't be any further from the truth
actually ishin today has had not one but
two epic entrances I feel that the more
memorable one would be the one in the
aranca arc sure turning the tides
against aizena's calling all but him
saving Khan from Grand Fisher while
revealing that he's quite the powerful
Shinigami was a big change in the status
quo it's a Twist that Savvy people saw
coming but when is that ever weakened
the impact of a hype moment you can see
it coming but when it does happen it's
as awesome as it's ever been ishin also
one shot of freshly powered up ground
Fisher so that's really something too
[Music]
now we all saw ishin was a joke
character in the early arcs but we at
least knew he was alive unlike this next
father
yes igneel the same igneel were left to
believe was gone for half the series
makes his return to even the odds in the
Hopeless battle against acnologia that's
just no way for the heroes and their
attacks to reach the all-powerful
acnologia and with the threat of face
looming in the distance they needed
bigger backup and that backup came in
the form of igneel who burst out of
Natsu it's an awesome Cliffhanger to an
episode and one that made all fairy tale
fans feel emotional igneel finally
returned in full glory to take on
acnologia in The Clash of the Titans
that everyone wanted that's the
highlight of the Ark and it all started
from a surprising return that had
everyone all hyped the moment was just
pure awesomeness never mind the rest of
the Dragons soon coming back to help
while the heroes battle their respective
opponents the tartarasark is amazing in
its own ways
we've all had heroic examples so how
about changing a little bit now and
featuring yujiro
[Music]
when it comes to yujiro you expect a
Burly Beast of a man someone who comes
in heralded by thunder and lightning
striking fear into the hearts of
everyone just look at how intimidating
his verbal introduction was look at how
much the characters hyped his prowess
now did you expect something this over
the top jumping straight out of a
helicopter before swinging into a
building is something you'd expect agile
secret agents would do but boy did he
completely pull it off perfectly
everyone's reaction says it all this
completely came out of the left field
but in a way it also fits yujiro to do
something as big as this and be the Talk
of the Town eujiro has got a lot of
Great Moments both in the classic Barky
and the modern Sequel and this ranks
somewhere high up there
Endeavor has one of these you know
[Music]
how could Endeavor out of all people not
join the party it's something he won't
allow in universe and with how cool this
scene was it's also something that I'd
love to be part of the list we've had a
lot of discussion on Endeavor fights and
how awesome they are but how about this
entrance it comes out of nowhere
delivering a punch filled with so much
power you can feel it beyond the screen
such a grand and Powerful entrance is oh
so fitting for endeavor he's all
straight to business which also gives
some good contrast with all might come
to think of it whereas the latter lets
the moment sink in and seems to relish
how his grand entrance will come as a
source of relief to others Endeavor goes
straight to the explosions and the power
moves a go-getter and a perfectionist in
the truest sense of the word endeavor
really deserves this kind of entrance
it's filled with energy and power much
like how yujiro does his
foreign
s make you want to watch full episodes
of anime unfortunately from where I am
such a thing isn't easy that's why I
have to thank today's sponsors
expressvpn expressvpn is your
trustworthy partner when you browse the
internet you see anime despite its
popularity has actually got quite a
limited distribution I know that sucks
but I managed to hold out thanks to
expressvpn all you need to do is find a
server click the button wait for it to
connect and voila you get those
streaming sites thinking you're in the
US and it opens a wide variety of shows
that you can now legally enjoy and
that's not all it's not just your
account on streaming sites that gets
protected expressvpn provides Extra
Protection from spying entities that
plague the internet Packers not so
pleasant government agencies companies
wanting your data you know the list just
goes on and expressvpn is here to deal
with them by protecting your activity
data you can get three months of
expressvpn for free by following the
link below or typing in
www.expressvpn.com vinitube open a brand
new horizon in your life on the Internet
only with the best VPN service in town
expressvpn it's time to go back to the
classics with Goku arriving to fight
Frieza
with even the mighty Vegeta falling
against the power of Frieza all hope is
lost however hope is never lost if
Goku's around and our main character
uses his chance to make his grand
entrance to namik the perfect opponent
to try and put an end to frieza's
Ambitions and while this entrance isn't
as bombastic in modern standards it's
the thought that counts I just can't
imagine how it feels to be a DBZ fan
back when this was first airing and
seeing Goku save the day Frieza has
already been properly hyped and Goku
making his Grand return gives the
feeling of two Unstoppable forces
colliding this is Peak Goku not in terms
of power but in terms of presence you
can tell everyone knows the battle's
taken a completely different turn upon
his arrival in the scene
foreign
if you're up for something flashier more
eye-catching in the traditional way we
have minato's arrival for you
what's the most awesome way to enter The
Fray it won't be Undisputed top of the
list but warping away the ten Tails
attack while arriving in such a cool
pose has to be up there and that's what
Minato just did in this scene that we'll
be remembering for a very long time ever
since the garges got revived in the
final Naruto Arc we all knew they were
going to do something amazing but it's
just so fitting that Minato not only
arrives first but also does the heavy
lifting minato's arrival marks a major
breakthrough in the alliance
counter-attack I like how the Epic
moment also manages to throw in some
comedic banter to lighten the mood after
the alliance just faced a complete wipe
seconds ago it also gave the floor for
the other car games and Sasuke to make
it back and maybe give everyone a
Fighting Chance not only does this scene
depict an epic entrance by an anime Dad
it's also one of the most amazing ways
the hero team gets saved
wrapping this list up is dragon's
arrival
[Music]
now this is a moment that's pure
unadulterated presence dragon's Got The
Look to put it off and the way he saved
Luffy from smokers surely got one piece
fans worldwide off their seats stunned
in awe the rain and thunder just adds to
the moment so much giving dragon that
extra oomph to this entrance he didn't
crash into the scene or stop a world
ending attack with this one but the
energy is just there the presence is so
overwhelming and this arrival sets the
stage perfectly for the Showcase of
power Dragon proceeds to show all right
foreign
that just about wraps up this list what
do you think is the best father entrance
on the list and what do you think can
also make it into this list I'd love to
hear from you so head on to our social
media all the links are in the
description and the team would love to
have you as part of the community or you
could just write in the comments
engagement is good for the algorithm and
I'd love nothing better than for the
Channel's videos to do well thanks for
watching I hope you have a great day
ahead and I'll see you in the next video